[Music]
I can feel the beat in our morning
rounds we're looking at wearable
technology is a more than 21 billion
dollar market and it is on track to
reach nearly 35 billion dollars in the
next four years smartwatches are driving
the trend Apple has sold more than 50
million of the devices since it started
selling them in 2015 the company is
launching two new Apple watch features
later today for heart health
we met Apple's chief operating officer
Jeff Williams and vice president of
Health dr. symbolic Desai to learn how
the Apple watch is tracking a disorder
that affects at least 2.7 million
Americans the digital crown actually has
electrodes on it as does the back of the
watch and by putting your finger on that
digital crown you're actually closing
the circuit on the watch and over the
counter fda-cleared electrocardiogram is
built into the body of the Apple watch
series for air closing your circuit to
able to measure the electrical signals
and impulses that are coming from your
heart Apple says this new test which
takes about 30 seconds can detect atrial
fibrillation or afib a condition where
the heart beats out of rhythm like it
says this ECG does not show signs of
atrial fibrillation afib often has no
symptoms but it can lead to a stroke the
ECG app is one of two new features that
tracks it the other periodically checks
a user's heart rhythm and sends an alert
if an irregular rhythm is detected you
know we didn't wake up one day and say
we made an iPhone and iPad and now let's
go after healthcare it really happened
organically Jeff Williams is Apple's
chief operating officer why concentrate
on the heart first we have more heart
rate monitors on people's wrists than
anybody else in the world we have tens
of millions of heartrate monitors we
originally put the heart rate monitor on
just to track your activity we didn't
put it on as a medical device
dear mr. Cook art the more we started
getting letters where people said it
detected something serious and in some
cases helped save their lives the more
we realize we have a huge opportunity to
do so that heart
alerts just kept going off off in us who
else knows about my health care data we
care deeply about privacy and so with
our technology all your health
information including these ECGs are
stored encrypted on your device and
encrypted in the cloud to back it up and
you alone decide who you share it with
period it could be scary if you think of
yourself as a healthy individual and all
of a sudden you get a false a fib um it
could be on the flip side there's also
if you get a fib and you didn't know and
you actually end up having something
else happen like a stroke that's even
the potential outcome and the
life-changing impact that you're gonna
have as a result is potentially even
scarier as an executive did you ever say
I'm not sure we want to go here let's
let's go slowly yeah we have gone
through this very very carefully and
thoughtfully but there will be some
false positives we think the impact on
the other side far outweighs that the
ECG app will be available on Apple watch
series for later today the irregular
rhythm notification feature is for Apple
watch series 1 and later both require
software updates that can be found in
the Apple watch app and I know dr. taryn
Rula is here with us she is a
cardiologist you've been wearing this
testing it so interesting what are the
upsides essentially to being able to
determine or detect an irregular
heartbeat
it sounds like what's the big deal with
an irregular heartbeat well a fib is a
big deal it affects millions of
Americans increases hospitalization
rates over 700,000 hospitalization
hospitalizations a year increases death
and heart failure but as you mentioned
in the piece stroke stroke scan be
debilitating and life-altering it
increases stroke risk by five times the
problem with afib is that can be
asymptomatic so you can be walking
around and not know you have it while
you're at increased risk of stroke if it
you are symptomatic the tests that we
currently have are either short-term
monitors that you wear for a day or a
couple weeks or an implantable monitor
said something like this could really
bridge the gap and I started wearing
mine just a couple months ago and I'm so
hooked because Nora was raving about it
so was John but it's pricey about $400
do you think it's worth the cost how do
you put a value on empowering patients
and in my mind this is a tool that helps
to empower people it puts you in the
driver's seat when you're a patient
you're any
but in power position you are vulnerable
you are scared here we're saying look
take control of your health see what's
happening go to your doctor have a
conversation and so it really opens that
door and it changes the the discussion
from a point where you meet the doctor
of a couple months to where you may be
interfacing all the time your downside
quickly definitely anxiety false
positives so flooding doctors offices
with calls you know there are definitely
downsides but I think this has the
potential to really be very helpful down
the road could save your life having
afib and then we have treatments for it
you know blood thinners that can
decrease stroke risk Thank You Tara very
yeah always good to have you here